captives are no longer that great at
stopping Bots but Google continues to
push captcha and to put resources behind
it for Google captcha offers tremendous
value before they were able to train
their text recognition technology and
the digitized books using captcha now
they're able to collect millions of
hours worth of human image recognition
and a general website usage data that
can be used for machine learning and
training Ai and it doesn't stop right
there either Google is also able to
collect data about our most important
online activity our most important
online activity is usually the stuff
that's guarded by captures giving Google
direct access to the specific data which
is way more valuable than our general
online usage